last year gordon tried to turn around
restaurants across the country in a
moment you'll see how they're doing
today but first a look back at what the
handlebar was like last year hello
handlebar how can i help you this
upscale community is located on long
island and when chef ramsay showed up
last year he soon found out he was in
for one of the biggest challenges of his
career
before buying the handlebar with his
wife carolyn bill leroy was a
construction worker oh boy his only
restaurant experience eating out they
look disgusting i don't know why anybody
orders them as for a chef well she hated
her job i'm not a chef i don't claim to
be a chef i don't want to be a chef i
not very creative
and the people hated her cooking the
food is
crap i think hiring me wasn't
necessarily the best idea
and to make matters worse billy was in
denial about everything
i never really had complaints about the
food so not surprisingly billy and
carolyn were going broke we took out
equity line of credit that's almost
maxed out and drains our savings account
god help us if the handlebar fails we'd
risk losing our house when chef ramsay
arrived he quickly found out that the
handlebar cuisine was the restaurant's
biggest problem seafood crepe yeah
that's seafood crap this is the worst of
it i'm sure
uh
it comes out looking like dog food
[Music]
that was rancid pointless tasteless a
complete utter joke oh my god what a
disaster after an unbelievably bad lunch
chef ramsay was in for another shock
have you lost your passion i never had a
passion to begin with
[Music]
i i don't want to be a chef
i didn't think our situation was as bad
as i'm finding out minute by minute
[Music]
that night gordon observed dinner
service i don't need this
and although there was complaint after
complaint i don't like it at all
the only person who seemed not to notice
was billy really customers are
complaining about the food
you can't walk around oblivious the fact
that you think this is good yeah but
it's not bad in everybody's opinion
[Music]
whatever
the next morning chef ramsay got up
early to conduct an inspection of the
walk-in and what he found was a
disgusting disgrace the reminiscence of
exxon valdez
oh my god almighty
that there was a clam
what a mess when was the last time this
fridge was cleaned a week ago oh no no
no it hasn't i'm sorry 21 years in the
business i'll bet every [ __ ] dollar i
have this [ __ ] place hasn't been
cleaned in years i'm disgusted put your
hand down there
everything's coming out and this place
is gonna get cleaned
instead of taking responsibility billy
went outside to pout
but chef ramsay was not about to let him
off the hook
i'm [ __ ] pissed off
and i'm upset on the kind of [ __ ] that
i've just discovered in there time to
drag me through the mud some more
it is what it is
if you don't see one [ __ ] ounce
bothered about it billy you can't just
stick your head back in the sand ignore
it billy sure you can
[Music]
you're a weak man billy
i really i'm glad you had enough
finished can you talk to me no
billy can you talk to me please nope i
have nothing to say
billy
i wouldn't talk to my dog the way you
talk to me go [ __ ] yourself that's right
you didn't have to act like a baby
he's telling you the truth though billy
great there's ways to go about it
46 years old never been talked to like
that by anybody and you know what the
only thing that's keeping me from
[ __ ]
hitting him with a [ __ ] baseball bat
is that i'd go to [ __ ] jail for it
i'm done and you're not the man everyone
here thought you were billy absolutely
not
so help me god i will not open the door
tomorrow and you can all go [ __ ]
yourselves and i don't care if it's all
for nothing what a week man
billy walked benny
leaving his wife carolyn holding the bag
let me help you
i want you to help me but i don't know
what to do i have a job that i have to
work so i can pay my mortgage sure
okay
i don't know what to do
for that night's dinner service chef
ramsay put some changes into effect
first he created a new host specialty
melissa let's do a special tonight some
fried clams with a homemade tata sauce
it switched lambs then he introduced a
new signature touch for the handlebar
the minute the customer rides the table
they sit down and we need to give them
fresh hand-cut
homemade potato chips a warm welcome
no those are good
that night there were two shocking
sights in the restaurant happy customers
they said that's the best thing that
they've ever had here so it's going
really good and the return of billy
billy
please
i love you
that's all that matters
that's all that matters
the man is one of the top chefs in the
world
and um maybe i should um
put aside the ill feelings and listen to
what they ask to say seriously i'm
pleased you're back yeah hey you're the
you're the foundation of this place
but soon after billy's return the
kitchen began to fall apart killing me
whatever god help us
and chef melissa fell far behind melissa
has to talk now this is the most crucial
stage of the service where she has to
open up and and talk and get help from
there
it's just delicate with so many tables
on with billy now accepting some of the
problems of the restaurant chef ramsay
decided to put his plan into action
re-launch tomorrow night
we have to make it a success get some
sleep yes
[Music]
after billy and his staff left gordon's
crew worked overnight and completely
remodeled the handlebar
ready let's have a look
let's go
here we
go oh
[Music]
oh my god it's gorgeous this place looks
awesome
[Music]
we are no longer stuck in the 80s
look at it
warm bright vibrant happy yes
but gordon's biggest change wasn't the
remodel he transformed the handlebar
into long island's first gastropub the
gastro club is warm open all hours come
and relax and enjoy whether it's the
steak
mussels the salmon the sausage it's
perfect for the neighborhood
good evening
welcome thank you the town came out to
support handlebar for relaunch night
local rock star d snyder from the band
twisted sister made a loud entrance
but very early on in the dinner service
it appeared as though the big night was
about to go up in flames
chef melissa was rushing and trying to
do everything herself i think it's okay
no way madam yeah
i'm not serving charcoal [ __ ] like that
no
[ __ ] disgusting
foods started coming back this is a cook
look at the middle of the [ __ ] salmon
gross that's when chef ramsay knew he
had to step in and get melissa back on
track melissa use these two guys i'm
trying i want to hear it
open up communicate yeah i need three
arb tries
we are doing real well let's keep it up
and for the first time since gordon
arrived melissa was in complete control
and as for the customers
they love the new menu
a great menu right i'm surprising myself
now
at the end of the evening for the first
time since billy took over the staff
felt a sense of pride hope and success
well done this place is going to be a
success i tell you
congratulations on being long island's
first gastropub
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's been a year since gordon first
arrived at handlebar and now he's back
this is the alleyway where billy walked
out last year so through these tough
times is billy hanging in and his
handlebar's still here
[Music]
for chef ramsay the handlebar in long
island new york was a disaster from the
moment he walked in an angry owner you
can all go [ __ ] yourselves and i don't
care if it's all for nothing
a lazy chef
i think hiring me wasn't necessarily the
best idea
and awful food it comes out looking like
dog food
it took a great deal of effort but
gordon managed to make an amazing
transformation of the handlebar in just
a few days congratulations on being long
island's first gastro club
now one year later has billy taken
gordon's advice or has he reverted to
his old stubborn ways
first time i came here was like stepping
back in time old-fashioned decor old
rotten food also one of the most
stubborn owners i've ever come across in
my entire life but we changed all that
and created long island's first ever
gastropub i cannot wait to see how
they're doing
hello
billy am i pleased to see you very great
hi sir lightweight it's good to see you
yeah that big smile on your face good to
see you what are you doing when gordon
walked through the door today my
heart stopped how are you both good so
nice to see you looking happy yeah no
thing thing's actually been doing pretty
well good how's he been still very
stubborn but you know he's better than
he was before on a scale to one to ten
is stubbornness where are we ten ten oh
it's better than eleven this time a year
ago
you think this is good
yeah but it's not bad in everybody's
opinion
who's in the kitchen melissa melissa
yeah that's great news you know
i didn't think she'd be here to be
honest
you gotta be kidding me oh i'm gonna
hang myself
how are you
how are you today nice to see you my
darling always a pleasure always a
pleasure it was surprisingly uh not
horrible to see gordon last time i saw
you you told me you didn't care you
didn't give a fake you didn't want to be
a chef i don't want to cook anymore
it's uh you know it's a whole new world
just showed me the like gordon i'm so
happy you know that yes sir
why is everybody looking so happy what's
the secret you got to stay upbeat
listen to you mr motivator i'm a lot
more confident now i really tend to be
more involved and want to see this
succeed but there's one thing i want to
see
yeah before i taste the food okay is
what
the walking billy oh okay let's go in
there okay i ran in the other direction
when gordon wanted to go into the
refrigerator because i know what
happened back there last time
oh my god almighty that there was a clam
i'll bet every [ __ ] dollar i have
this [ __ ] place hasn't been cleaned
in years i'm disgusted
oh my god it's immaculate yeah and
everything's fresh the difference is
night and day yup i cannot believe the
difference i definitely wanted him to be
impressed i'm glad he was really happy
with everything is that cleaning down i
felt like eating my lunch off the floor
are you happy
with your gastropub yes we're very happy
with the new direction that we were
set in and we're trying to stay on that
track you
were
frustrated last time i saw you
let me help you
i want you to help me but i don't know
what to do i have a job that i have to
work so i can pay my mortgage
how have you been personally well i
think this year has been better for me
um billy is handling the restaurant
much more efficiently and he feels
better about it
good luck
hi thank you
within a short time of arriving at
handlebar it quickly became clear to
gordon that billy was a changed man how
you doing
doing it's what an interesting ride huh
seriously yeah absolutely yeah when you
were here last time things were really
took off and then all of a sudden the
economy just wow yeah
yeah what a ride very interesting yeah
last time i was here
you were stubborn
as hell i mean like really stubborn
finished can you talk to me no
billy can you talk to me please no
i have nothing to say
billy
i wouldn't talk to my dog the way you
talk to me go [ __ ] yourself
[Music]
yup it's hard sometimes to hear the
truth
you were right i was wrong
[Music]
i'm not i'm not too proud to admit it
i was an angry person back then i mean
it all goes back to being able to take
criticism some people can some people
can't
i still haven't met
in nearly
coming up to 100 kitchen nightmares
a man that was as stubborn as [ __ ]
you
i've got to say that you know that
what made me change and click with that
is that i should listen because if i
don't i'm going to crash and burn and
there is going to be no restaurant and i
am going to be going to bankruptcy court
and i am going to be losing it all
everything that i've worked my whole
life for chips are here oh yeah still
doing them i can't really much say is
the cooks like them because they are
very time consuming now time consuming
but what about the customers though oh
they all love it i've had people ask me
if we could package them
and sell them they're bloody delicious
wow thank you my donny you're quite
welcome
enjoy oh lovely that's a martini
marinated fillet
[Music]
so tender a little bit different than
the last time you had something to eat
here
it really made me happy when he was
happy with the food the best and the
worst moment last time i was here
the best moment was when i walked
through the door and seen the new look
of the restaurant
happy yes
[Music]
and the worst moment
the worst moment was getting all the
phone calls billy left billy left
i'm done
[Music]
billy
[Music]
billy
[Music]
the fact you've turned it around
we left the prescription
you took the remedy and it's worked and
this is very tough out there oh yeah the
economy and the best restaurants across
the globe are closing yes they are in
their hundreds yeah so for this to turn
the corner and survive we can just tread
water now yes these next six months yep
trust me it will come back yeah that's
what we're hoping i was very happy that
he was proud of what we did well done
guys i'm so pleased honestly and more
importantly stick to it continue
evolving it yeah continue being the
backbone if it wasn't for him
we wouldn't have been at this point that
is delicious i'm glad you enjoy it can i
take it to go absolutely
[Music]
come here
well done
excellent
in 20 years
this is the happiest i think billy's
been because we are going in the right
direction i say thanks gordon i think
you really
tried to do
the best you could for us and now it's
up to us to keep it going
unbelievable this time a year ago billy
was about to throw the towel in and i
seriously wandered through these tough
times if handlebars was honestly going
to make it but the good news is
handlebars is thriving and so is billy
and that says a lot
about an hour's drive east of los
angeles sits the sleepy high desert town
of lancaster
before chef ramsay arrived casaroma was
known for two things bad food
and slow service not one table not one
tables have their food yet
running the kitchen was a grumpy chef
named eric
that's [ __ ] and you know it
who in between frequent smoke breaks if
somebody wants me i'm not back
created greasy delicacies like this
the restaurant was owned by a mother's
son team got to get this place turned
these two bosses took more orders from
their head chef than they gave him nyla
i have a nice water please
way to go
she's standing right there
you want to start on those pieces then
relax take a chill
chef ramsay had no idea that he was
walking into one of the most poorly won
restaurants in america just out of
interest with no previous rational
experience anywhere why would you open a
restaurant if you've never worked on one
because we're insane
chef ramsay then decided to do something
no one else in town was interested in
doing anymore
having lunch at casa roma people say
well he's a five-star michelin chef okay
so he's got four tires and a spare kiss
my ass that means nothing to me
[Music]
is that popular no
[Music]
jesus i'm not worried about him but see
what he's got if he wants to [ __ ] and
moan that's his drama it's actually
dripping
[Music]
fat
outraged chef ramsay assembled a staff
meeting and it didn't take long for
things to get ugly lunch
absolutely embarrassing
the fried sandwich i what planet are you
on when you put that [ __ ] together
it was a bad [ __ ] day pal now you're
pushing away enough i get it we
understand
a bad day yeah [ __ ] happens
you never had a bad day i do have bad
days all the time actually having one
today just relax take a chill pill
reload and do it again
there's nothing editable
we're out of work
why are you walking away eric
so i don't [ __ ] rip your head off
that night at dinner service nyla and
jeremy had zero control over their staff
especially their head chef okay guys
listen worst shrimp scampi they ever had
and they said no flavor at all you know
what can you do
as dish after dish was sent back by
angry customers
it looks like it's frozen i'm sorry
about that guy
eric seemed to care less and less when
food comes out like that assumes you
never taste it
you know what can you do
oh damn after a couple of hours of
complete chaos and barely any food going
out chef ramsay had seen enough we're
spinning around and serving [ __ ]
do me a favor close the [ __ ]
restaurant i can't stand any longer and
watch that embarrassment as of now we're
not gonna be serving any more dinners
tonight i need
the door [ __ ] clothes forget it all
right we're done for the night
this is a joke guys you're pissed off
you're frustrated forget it good night
moments later gordon had a heart to
heart with nyla
why are you employing a chef that is
that incompetent
have you got any chance surviving here
get rid of him what are you scared of
talk to me there's got to be something
am i gonna or i need to find another
chef so drew what's wrong with drew drew
i think can carry it off so get rid of
him
nyla saw the light and some of the
courage to finally stand up for herself
the whole thing is this this isn't the
first time you've let us down
i don't i just can't do it i know but i
can't do it okay so what do you want to
do
we're going to part way okay okay
[Music]
but eric was not casarama's only problem
the next morning chef ramsay found
[Music]
another god
before we go any further i want the
[ __ ] place cleaner while the staff
clean
gordon's crew came in to give casaroma a
complete makeover
[Applause]
we got a nice new bride
carpets have gone
[Music]
then gordon unveiled casaroma's brand
new menu
this is doable uncomplicated nothing
frozen and freshly home baked pizza wow
when the doors of the restaurant opened
for the relaunch the people of lancaster
came in droves willing to give the new
casaroma another chance
the wings
but within minutes it started to feel
like the old casaromo
look at me
they gotta go in the pan and in the oven
not even hot in the center what's going
on
come on
relaunch night was starting to look more
like closing night for carceroma it soon
became apparent that drew wasn't quite
ready to be a head chef take a deep
breath stop pushing me and just chill
you're making me hurry [ __ ] up i can't
okay have anything to [ __ ] do it go
for it
i need some form of quality control guys
yeah most important thing here is
[ __ ] standard slow down and pay
attention to detail yeah gotta pull it
together after gordon's message of
quality over speed sunk in drew finally
pulled it together and although the
relaunch wasn't perfect it was a success
[Music]
for the first time owners nyla and
jeremy and the staff of casaroma savored
the sweet taste of success
trust me if everyone does their bits
three months down the line this place is
going to be rocking
now it's time to see how they're doing
today
i'm back in lancaster california to
visit casaroma now everyone in the town
knew about casaroma that's right they
knew to say the hell out of there i'm
dying to see if they've turned the
corner
gordon ramsay will never forget his time
at casa roma from the first meal it's
actually dripping
fat ill
to the crazy chef
it was a bad [ __ ] day pal now you're
pushing it enough i get it we understand
and of course the owners nyla and jeremy
who had no control over the restaurant
was that any anything on that last order
ready or close relax take a chill
somehow gordon got through to the staff
thank god for ramsey
and made some dramatic changes to turn
casaroma around
now a year later it's time to see if
this lancaster pizzeria is still on the
path to success last time i was here you
had a mother and a son that were
weighing over their heads a chef that
was quite possibly the worst in america
and the kitchen that was so foul it made
me vomit however we did make some
changes and i'm dying to find out what's
going on
here we go
[Music]
hello hi hello how are you my darling i
think of gordon as a mentor to me and
now i i think of it as a friend how's
business business is good we're doing
good yep please tell me we didn't bring
eric back no no no no eric when food
comes back like that the shrimps you
never taste it
you know what can you do
drew he's no longer with us
take a deep breath stop pushing me in
just chill okay you're making me hurry
[ __ ] up i can't okay have anything to
[ __ ] do it go for it um relationship
with jeremy how was it um jeremy's not
with me anymore really
i love my son to death you know i love
all my kids
but
we just couldn't work together you've
had a clear house huh you'd be spring
cleaning gordon influenced me a lot i
mean the day he left here he told me you
need to buy him out
i think he's created a little bit of a
monster
oh god shall i yeah whoa
[ __ ] it now
oh god
[Music]
bloody hell
everything's fresh my god and look how
organized it is i'm very proud of the
place now we have people who cleaned her
in the mornings we have people who clean
at night we have everybody on board look
how spotless this place is as well how
about that huh right how you doing sir
wait a second
i recognize this man
how are you doing um first name is kim
from sebastian yeah possibly one of the
most difficult
arrogant jumped-up owners i've ever met
in my entire life someone say that yeah
i'm just so [ __ ] disappointed you're
gonna count down stop pointing your
finger at me are we gonna speak like men
you're gonna speak to me like a man
listen you're not listening to what i'm
saying
what in the hell are you doing here good
question i had seen this show about
sebastian's and i watched and q was
really on track
he came in and talked to me i recognized
him and so
we hired him so what happened to
sebastian well i mean i left um one day
it's out of nowhere it kind of
disappeared no yeah this experience
compared to my last experience with
gordon was definitely more pleasant i
will say um so how's how's business
business is good since i've gotten q in
here and we've changed everything out we
went from having two dinners a night to
having 28 to 30. fantastic we're
probably doing
at least a third more for months
now than we were a year ago
you're a soft target last time i saw you
what have you done to make sure you draw
that line of the sand well i made
believers out of someone that i got rid
of
and even though they were good they had
just gotten too comfortable i'm not
gonna put up any more ball the biggest
thing gordon taught me was to have the
bollocks to stand up
and not let anybody push me around
anymore and i don't
no diane there he is thank you look at
that oh wow thank you that was seven
minutes from the time i ordered last
time i was here 75 minutes in between
courses right before gordon took that
first bite of steak i thought uh-oh i
love steak dying another everybody loves
it
isn't it good the meat's so tender wow
that's so delicious
once he took a bite and he liked it i
was very
relaxed i want you to come with me
yeah i got a little surprise
nyla as part of the animal valley
chamber of commerce and the city of
lancaster we would like to give you this
certificate you've been really good to
the community and we'd like to thank you
[Applause]
it was nice to have somebody pat you on
the back and give you a atta boy
ready one two three
excellent i'm so proud
[Applause]
i can't do it alone and everybody helps
and i knew if i talked too long i would
be crying because it's just nice
thank you all for everything well done
excellent
he put me through a boot camp for about
a week it was good for me
[Music]
[Applause]
what a relief the difference is night
and day but honestly the biggest change
is in nyla because she clearly isn't
scared of making decisions and let's be
honest it's clearly working good on her
once upon a time in the city of
manhattan there was a place called the
black pearl a restaurant run by three
different owners
sleepy aka brian was the one who never
talked i just asked brian he's like yeah
you guys can figure it out can we always
figure it out
dopey or greg could never make a
decision
that's why i sometimes waffle and go
back and forth
and grumpy was david who was arrogant
and defensive gordon the [ __ ] truth
is that i'm back there when it's busy
every [ __ ] night that i work
it didn't take long for chef ramsay to
realize this was no fairy tale this is
not gonna be a good thing
my name is steven so if anything just
let me know thank you i like you were
enthusiasm by the way thank you
while gordon was pleased with the
service the food was just the opposite
horrible it's like eating a [ __ ] wet
diaper
[Music]
night during dinner service the
customers agreed with chef ramsay the
food was inedible
i need an order of fried shrimp this one
was undercooked
i'll take this bag
gordon quickly realized that one of
black pearl's biggest problems was the
quality of the food what do you smell
phil it smells old
you seem a very relaxed man with your
rice what do you want me to do i
disagree it doesn't smell bad to me the
fish i've just given a piece of your
chef yeah the piece was stinking it
wasn't stinking you're blind my friend
if you're not blind you're [ __ ]
clueless you know that
but that was just the beginning gordon
discovered that the restaurant's main
lobster was a fraud
they look canadian lobster to me yeah
these are too many
they're not main lobsters
you tell me about the passion with the
main lobster are you aware that the
lobsters in your fridge are canadian
same waters north atlantic waters
tell me is it a different animal
maine
is a canadian lobster for you a martis
americanus same animal right
they're not from maine well it comes
from the same vendor
holy [ __ ]
the next day a staff meeting quickly
disintegrated into another battle
between gordon and david david why
haven't we got aprons if they know where
the aprons are they just don't choose to
wear them but why can't you say its
policy to be in an apron cat it's a
policy for you not to have a drink here
after your shift but you often do david
show the girl some respect really in
front of everybody why can't you answer
the [ __ ] question
i thought i did answer the question do
you know what i've just discovered
you're so full of [ __ ] [ __ ] you'd
make a great politician you know that
confused by three different directions
from three different owners gordon
suggested a staffer and they elected
greg as the general manager i'd
definitely like to give it a shot for
sure with a new leader in charge gordon
went ahead with his plan to give the
black pearl a complete facelift ready
yeah let's go
[Music]
everything is uniform wow
much better but grumpy david was not
impressed davey what do you think
columns should be yellow
[Music]
in order to add some excitement in the
dining room gordon shipped in an
appropriate surprise now i promise you
you'll never find another machine
anywhere like this in new york and david
i promise you now this is from maine
of course if they catch it they eat it
does it blow me away no in spite of
david's negativity chef ramsay was
working hard to turn the black pearl
around right two chowders yes manhattan
clam chowder new england clam chowder
yeah the lobster roll black pearl uh
special and it's gonna be toasted on the
inside as well okay so it doesn't go
soggy and then we go to the boston cream
pie and uh a waffle sundae
but david as expected was still grumpy
you say
good not ceviche good
i don't like it mm-hmm really i like
that shrimp thing either
[Music]
on relaunch night
with greg running the show david and
brian came to eat and mostly criticize
the lanterns these things are terrible
fish are good candles
the evening was a big success
[Music]
every table was happy well except for
one service sucks here kitchen must be
fair
[Music]
after dinner while the staff celebrated
chef ramsay met with the three owners
one final time and that's when the
gloves came off my advice is for him to
get his partners get your money out yeah
and disappear yeah all right well my
advice would be for you to disappear and
the sooner the better i've never met an
individual that's so full of [ __ ] in all
my life how have i been lying to you
cordy how tom gordy yeah how want to
just respect me i can disrespect you too
but tell me how tell me tell me i'm not
disrespecting you i'm telling you the
truth disrespect me because you don't
know the truth you're just massaging
your [ __ ] ego you're wrong
the great gordon ramsay is wrong you
don't get it do you
[ __ ] you gordon of course i get it this
russian has every chance of succeeding
but not why you are in it
why don't you come back in and you know
i'm sure you will and see how it goes
[Music]
i'm back in new york city to let you
know what happened to my friends at the
black pearl you're not gonna believe
this
in manhattan the black pearl was under a
black cloud i'm about four grand short
of payroll and the prince of darkness
was an owner named david doesn't blow me
away no who never appreciated anything
that chef ramsay had done to turn around
his restaurant you're wrong it seemed
all he wanted to do was fight the great
gordon ramsay is wrong
dave must have been the most arrogant
russian owner i've ever met in my entire
life and guess what he is no longer a
russian owner as i predicted the black
pearl is closed kaput finished
down
hello
ramsay gordon nice to see you damon down
nice to meet you daymond
it's changed that's for sure it
certainly has yeah black belt
disappeared disappeared and the name is
the hard pick new york city
congratulations thank you very much did
you meet the owners yes yes i did oh
jesus sleepy grumpy dopey
let's not go there but um they weren't
really running
their place properly more importantly
business is going good very good going
great good i'm so pleased he's doing
well any chance of having a little
taster yeah i'm gonna take a seat and uh
wait for my uh lunch
last time i was at the black pearl
there's only one person in here that
actually told me the truth all the time
that was stephen so i'm gonna give him a
quick call let me get his butt down here
i can find out what really happened
oh wow
thank you all pork sliders thank you
it smells amazing
that's good
[Music]
stephen
chef ramsey how are you doing i'm good
good to see you nice to see you sit down
thank you what a shock um i know right
unbelievable what happened everything
kind of went back to the way that it was
the menu slowly reverted back to oh the
old menu no no no no
all right so what did you think of the
mean
pretty piss-pool to be honest
i'm gonna stop there thank you stephen
usually when i leave an establishment
after putting all that effort time money
into it
the owners leave excited
yeah not dave
what did he say after i left i guess you
left a bad taste in his mouth but nobody
likes being told about the wrong i got
invited in dave asked me to come here to
turn this place around he's not going to
take the advice and that's what i'd say
like you were i'm like remember this was
your idea you can't be mad or you can't
be angry when it was your idea to ask
for help the only time i saw him after
he left was when he had the staff
meeting telling us that the restaurant
was sold did you know how far behind it
was in terms of rent my last paycheck
from them bounced unbelievable i mean
david even sold your um lobster tank he
sold the lobster yeah i promise you
you'll never find another machine
anywhere like this in new york
it's only a dream a bit more you're
looking a bit scary i'm sorry get
yourself in and get some pool pool
would you like to try one sure um please
help yourself
[Music]
it's not delicious that is really good
you dating
no no still single
people don't want relationships in the
city i've realized everybody
i just want to have sex
i'm cool with that
just don't lead me on
so you like the pulled pork yes i do
are you uncomfortable gordon
good to see you but it's nice to see you
too gordon thank you thank you so much
for coming back thank you well i'm so
sorry i didn't work out you know we
tried we tried [ __ ] hard yeah because
here we are now six months later this
place is doing phenomenally well well
thank you so much good to see you
thank
you and put some weight on
these guys could have really made it
here because this place is a great
location for perfect seafood ration but
when you mix incompetence and arrogance
it's a recipe for one thing and one
thing only chapter seven
[Music]
you